hello I'm Chris Holden president of the  five to the home council your this has  been a great show for us and one of the  things that stands out in my mind is the  camaraderie and all the communications  happening within the exhibition area  this is very important to us because  we're a member organization and it's  great to see not only the fact that we  have 3,000 people here but they're going  around the exhibition and really talking  with all the members at their standards  for me this is an excellent job hello my  name is Harvick taba I'm the director  general of the ftth Council Europe Milan  it's the 8th edition of the ftth  conference it's 3,000 people and I just  can say one thing it's great  you